when newlyweds mr. and mrs. Lee booked
their honeymoon to the city of love it
was a dream come true their friends had
wax lyrical about the French lifestyle
in the lap of the gods so they were not
expecting the rough tone of some of the
locals particularly those who work in
the service industry do have savage
savage you'll have everything
by this point the Chinese tourists are
feeling very uncomfortable and when the
waiter brings their food and drink
they're nervous about asking him another
question American we have a square 1/2
piece of bread grouchy treatment of
customers is bad for business
London has already overtaken Paris in
visitor numbers the Paris Chamber of
Commerce has launched a campaign to
counteract the situation where necessary
staff are teaching Parisians to be more
friendly and to perfect the fine art of
the smile Chinese visitors prefer to
spend their time shopping rather than
eating so there's no need to be
irritated if they just order something
simple from the menu and then leave it
doesn't mean they aren't happy they're
just operating on a tight schedule
Mahalo means good day in Chinese if
you're able to say a couple of words in
their language it pleases them because
they can see you're really making an
effort but the restaurant owner doesn't
come across as a willing learner his
customers and the average Parisian are
worlds apart Asian tourists whether they
come from Japan or China have their
mobile phones glued to their hands you
can't talk to them and you can't tell if
they enjoyed what they ate because they
always just smiled some Parisian
restaurant and hotel owners fail to
grasp the seriousness of the situation
high prices and mediocre quality is not
only affecting visitor numbers but also
the reputation of the nation which was
known to celebrate the joie de vivre but
maybe not anymore
young Kotex economy in times of economic
crisis people tend to withdraw and
become more conservative and distant
both privately and professionally and
then we have the fact that the French
have always considered themselves to be
the best at everything they think a
foreign tourists will keep on coming to
Paris regardless so that they don't have
to put in any effort but what can you
really to reach to those who take stuff
volunteers however seem to have a
different view hundreds of so-called
greeters can now be seen on the streets
of Paris showing visitors around free of
charge and doing what they can to polish
the tarnished French image most of the
time they are and so they get better the
change much cheaper here than in Norway
and looks very fresh I now have friends
from all over the world in Tel Aviv New
York and in South America we're in
contact via Facebook and email mr. and
mrs. Li are not going to let a grumpy
waiter spoil their honeymoon in fact
they're trying to take something
positive from the experience we try this
we come to France we
we want to try everything in in from our
city partners it's one part of our
travel France and its capital are still
among the most popular tourist
destinations but it might not stay that
way if visitors continue to take home
tales of the grouchy rather than the
charming French